.
WE WARN YOU SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
YOU'LL HEAR MAY BE OFFENSIVE.
>> HE JUST DIDN'T LOSE.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU HAVE FAITH IN
ELECTIONS NOW?
>> NO.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE 2020
ELECTION WAS STOLEN?
>> NO, I DON'T BELIEVE THE 2020
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE ASPECTS
OF THE 2020 ELECTION THAT WERE
UNFAIR.
>> IN ARIZONA, A REPUBLICAN
PARTY AT ODDS WITH ITSELF.
TRUMP AND PENCE HOLDING
COMPETING EVENTS FOR TWO VERY
DIFFERENT UNDERSTANDINGS OF
REALITY.
>> WE NEED A LANDSLIDE SO BIG
THAT THE RADICAL LEFT CANNOT RIG
IT OR STEAL IT, EVEN IF THEY
TRY.
>> AT TRUMP'S RALLY, A BONFIRE
OF CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS?
>> I HAVE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK THEY'RE A BUNCH OF
BULLSHIT.
>> WHY?
>> WELL, BECAUSE YOU HAVE BOTH
SIDES.
YOU'RE GETTING ONE SIDE OF THE
STORY.
>> YOU MEAN, LIKE, THE SIDE THAT
ATTACKED THE CAPITOL?
>> YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT
HAPPENED?
>> I WAS THERE.
>> OKAY.
I HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
THERE TOO.
>> AND?
>> AND SAW THINGS THAT IT WASN'T
WHAT THEY SAY IT WAS.
>> BUT THERE'S BEEN HUNDREDS OF
TRUMP SUPPORTERS NOW CHARGED.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE PLED GUILTY.
>> AND DO YOU THINK IT'S RIGHT
FOR THOSE PEOPLE TO HAVE THOSE
PEOPLE IN JAIL AND NOT GIVING ME
JUSTICE IN OUR AMERICAN SYSTEM?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS RIGHT
THAT THEY ATTACKED THE CAPITOL?
>> I DON'T -- THEY DIDN'T.
THAT WAS AN INSIDE JOB, BUDDY.
>> Reporter: VAST CONSPIRACY
THEORY THAT THOSE WHO STORMED
THE CAPITOL WERE NOT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IS WIDESPREAD HERE.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING THE
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS AT ALL?
>> NO.
>> WE SAW IT ALL GOING DOWN AND
BLM AND ANTIFA PEOPLE IN THE
BUILDING AS WELL.
>> I THINK 800 PEOPLE NOW HAVE
BEEN CHARGED.
>> YEAH.
>> NONE OF THEM ARE BLACK LIVES
MATTER OR ANTIFA.
>> THEY'RE NOT CHARGING --
>> THAT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
>> THEY HAVE NOT BEEN BROUGHT
INTO COURT FOR THEIR DUE PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ARRESTED.
>> HUNTER BIDEN HASN'T BEEN
>> TRUMP HAS TOLD LIES ABOUT THE
ELECTION IN THAT HE SAID HE
DIDN'T REALLY LOSE.
DO YOU THINK THAT ALL THE LIES
ABOUT THE ELECTION ARE DAMAGING
FOR AMERICAN DEMOCRACY?
>> YOU BELIEVE HE LIED?
>> DO YOU NOT?
>> NO, DO NOT.
WHY WOULD -- HE WON.
>> Reporter: BUT THESE ARE NO
LONGER FRINGE IDEAS.
A MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS DO NOT
BELIEVE BIDEN LEGITIMATELY WON
THE ELECTION.
THE PROUD BOYS, WHO TRUMP ONCE
INFAMOUSLY TOLD TO STAND BACK
AND STAND BY, NOW A REGULAR FIX
YOUR OUTSIDE HIS EVENTS.
>> ANY PROUD BOYS WANT TO TALK
TO US TODAY?
NO.
ARE YOU WATCHING JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS?
>> NO.
>> NOTHING TO SEE.
>> CNN, RIGHT?
>> CNN, YEAH.
NOT FANS?
OKAY.
>> Reporter: THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TO CAMPAIGN FOR
CONSPIRACY THEORIES SPOUTING
CANDIDATES SAYING THEY WOULD
HAVE OVERTURNED THE RESULTS OF
THE 2020 ELECTION IN ARIZONA,
LIKE KARI LAKE, CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR.
>> I KNOW FOR A FACT WE WILL NO
LONGER ACCEPT RIGGED ELECTIONS.
>> Reporter: PENCE CAMPAIGNING
FOR HER RIVAL.
>> Reporter: HERE WE MET SOME
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE DONE WITH
TRUMP.
>> I VOTED FOR TRUMP TWICE.
IF MIKE PENCE RUNS, I'M VOTING
FOR MIKE PENCE.
>> OKAY.
SO, WHY IS THAT?
>> I JUST THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE'S SEEN THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
HE STOOD UP FOR DEMOCRACY THAT
DAY.
HE'S LIKE, I'M NOT LEAVING THE
CAPITOL BECAUSE I NEED TO BE
HERE.
AND HE WAS THE ONE THAT WAS
MAKING PHONE CALLS TO THE
MILITARY AND TRYING TO FIX THE
SITUATION, WHILE TRUMP WAS
CRYING IN THE DINING ROOM.
>> BUT EVEN AMONG THIS CROWD,
THERE IS SYMPATHY FOR TRUMP'S
ELECTION LIES AND SUPPORT FOR A
2024 RUN.
>> YOU'RE ABOUT SEE PENCE SPEAK
HERE.
TRUMP'S NOT A BIG FAN OF HIM
RIGHT NOW.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
I HEAR THAT HE COULD HAVE NOT
CERTIFIED THOSE RESULTS, PENDING
ALL THE CLAIMS OF THE FRAUD.
AND I WISH HE WOULD HAVE DONE
THAT.
>> PENCE HAD NO LEGAL BASIS TO
DO THAT.
ALSO AMONG THOSE, RUSTY BOWERS,
A LIFE LONG REPUBLICAN AND
SPEAKER OF THE ARIZONA STATE
HOUSE.
>> WE'RE TALKING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN HERE TODAY WHO SAY
THEY'RE NOT EVEN -- THEY'RE NOT
WATCHING THE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS.
THEY STILL BELIEVE --
>> I KNOW.
>> -- THE LIES ABOUT THE 2020
ELECTION.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
>> I HAVE NO MESSAGE FOR THEM.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LOOK, YOU
DON'T WANT TO SEE, YOU WON'T
SEE.
I'VE SEEN ENOUGH TO KNOW.
AND I KNOW OTHER PEOPLE RIGHT IN
THIS ROOM HAVE DONE THEIR BEST
TO COUNT EVERYTHING AND DO IT
ALL RIGHT.
>> Reporter: HE TESTIFIED BEFORE
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE ABOUT
TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO GET HIM TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 RESULTS IN HIS
STATE.
>> WHAT IS THESE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THESE LIES ABOUT THE
ELECTION, ABOUT DEMOCRACY, WHAT
IS THAT DOING TO TRUST IN THIS
STATE?
>> IT DESTROYS IT.
IT DESTROYS IT.
WE'VE GOT TO LET THINGS GO.
>> WHAT WOULD NEED TO CHANGE FOR
YOU TO HAVE FAITH IN U.S.
DEMOCRACY?
>> I DON'T TRUST OUR GOVERNMENT
FIRST OF ALL, PERIOD.
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE FAIR
ELECTIONS, WHAT GOOD ARE YOU
THEY?
>> DO YOU EVER WORRY THAT YOU'RE
WRONG?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
>> DO YOU EVER WORRY TRUMP HAS
SOLD YOU A LIE?
>> YES, YOU START RESEARCHING
AND THINKING MAYBE I'M WRONG AND
I'M BEING BRAINWASHED AND
BELIEVING SOMETHING THAT
SOMEONE'S TELLING ME.
BUT THEN YOU GO IN AND LOOK THE
OTHER DIRECTION AND FIND LIES
AFTER LIES AFTER LIES.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT WAS
STOLEN O